good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about the why and the how
of running that I want you to remember
for the rest of your lives okay I want
you to listen closely
I'm giving you the key to life right now
this is the key to life the key to life
the key to life is running and reading
all right now listen very serious the
key to life is running and reading all
right now why running when you're
running and you have turn you're running
there's a little person that talks to
you and that little person says oh I'm
tired my lungs have to pop off so hard
I'm so tired there's no way I could
possibly continue and you want to quit
right
that person if you learn how to defeat
that person when you're running you will
learn how to wait when things get hard
in your life yeah I guess the question
comes you know why why did I end up
running as opposed to let's say playing
football at basketball at tennis for
some reason it just seemed more natural
it's just an unadorned and simple and a
like simple direct and and it didn't
seem like a game you know something that
I could practice at anytime anyplace
so it appealed to me because I could do
it all the time wherever I was no matter
where I could always run
basically a comparative physiologist I
started insects first how they solve
problems with respect to temperature and
all kinds of problems you know I had a
fascination you know a good kid but
maybe not much appreciation and I
appreciate it more and more because I
realized more and more how important it
is I was fascinated by running because
it's close to what many other animals do
when you see you know thousands of
people lining up for a race you know and
you think of all the dreams that are
there all packed in one one place they
all you know symbolically going on went
on a hunt after to the antelope or at
least take part of it I get I get broken
up with it you think about it
running is all about movement and it's
you know extreme movements and that
makes it very meaningful because
movement is really the essence of life
in a modern lifestyle we're not running
anymore
so we are basically disconnected from
what we previously had to do you know
most of us are out of shape and we don't
have to run for our hamburger or a
dinner
but deep down we're still all runners in
civil minds as much as your muscles are
part of this running phenotype so you
know I'm inspired no and by by people
who can really do great things so I
moved by other streams you know by the
devotion and courage pursuit of this
excellence and
yeah I mean especially you know kids
because you realize how much difference
it makes in the long run you know
how much little things matters and how
far they take you do the essential thing
is to rot period and to do it for a long
time consistently and and then
everything takes care of itself
just
well I guess yeah is it we're basically
all runners we all very start out very
very similarly and the trajectory we
take can be radically different
depending on the environmental stimuli
of course I'd really like to be a bird
but running is a close second
let's talk about running all right
first big picture this is what matters
and the body is just there to like keep
this thing running the brain feel great
I have not always been a runner
I ran cross-country in middle school
when I was like 11 I didn't really start
running until I was 26 27 28 28
what years
still on the Westside Highway
down the Midtown so I'm halfway up the
island where I was before
this is mile number six and I feel great
I didn't start running till I was 28
because when I was 26 I was told I'd
never be able to run again here's what
happened I'm gonna do this okay so I
borrowed Candace's scooter and I was
driving down the street and this dude
ran a red light and straight up just
cremated the scooter and my leg I was in
the hospital for about a week I was in
surgery for like 12 hours this is my
busted-up leg as soon as I got to the
hospital they did drill through my leg
with a drill to quickly put pressure on
it put it in traction to slow the
bleeding so when I was in the hospital
right before they were gonna release me
I asked the doctor how long till I'm
100% how long till I run and I'll never
forget he said to me you'll be able to
chase after your kids and you'll be able
to chase after a taxicab down the street
but you'll never be able to run again I
cannot tell you how much that freaked me
out I was 26 years old and being told
that I would never run again
it was devastated absolutely devastating
Hey still the Westside Highway on the
other end of this tunnel
now I'm uptown I'm coming into the
island here this is the 8-mile check-in
and I feel great okay I found the
footage all right so this is two years
after go to the hospital this was well
here those are my feet this is gross you
get the point
so my first marathon was an unmitigated
disaster
I really like got beat up i sat down I
was walking my time was abhorrent I hate
doing something and not being great at
it
okay this is the Upper West Side that
Central Park I just ran across the Upper
West Side I'm now entering Central Park
mile nine check in I feel great
four months later I ran my second
marathon and I really got I really got
it together okay this is the
southernmost point in Central Park
that's 59th Street this is check-in
number like 10 and change and I feel
great somewhere I decided that running
wasn't enough and I started to really
get into triathlons here's my favorite
picture of myself running a fast one
just look at that intensity
easternmost side of Central Park
that's Fifth Avenue there mile 12 and I
feel great
since being told by that doctor that I'd
never be able to run again
I've run 22 marathons I've competed in
four Ironman triathlons probably 100
other triathlons and other road races
and I never looked back I think it's
true to say that it was one of the best
feelings of our lives I mean to be able
to run with your children which which I
was lucky enough to do to run with your
children I think it's one of this great
great days of your life shorted out this
you know one of the one of the great
great moments of their lives support
makes it the best let me tell you about
this dream that I had this crazy dream
as ten years ago I decided to run the
New York City Marathon I wanted to raise
money for the public school system I
raised two million dollars
I even got a call from Oprah who said
that if I beat her marathon time she
would donate a lot of money to the cause
but there was a catch I had to finish
the whole thing I had to finish the
entire race now the marathon is 26.2
miles have any all been on a treadmill
for one mile wait 26.2 miles they ain't
a lot of brothers and sisters running
anything man now here's the crazy part
the recommended training time for
marathon is six months but I came up
with this idea with only eight weeks
left to Train only had eight weeks
nobody believed I would finish everybody
thought I was crazy but there was
something in me that just wouldn't
listen to no I made a decision and I was
gonna see that decision through now that
sounds all good I'm talking up to myself
all that sounds good but it's 26.2 miles
ahead of me now we get to the day of the
marathon I'm feeling good I just knew I
was gonna win the race so I was pushing
my way to the front of the line cuz I
feel like nobody's gonna take you to the
front of the line unless you push your
way to the front of the line let me tell
you that again nobody is gonna take you
to the front of the line unless you push
your way to the front of the line so I
pushed my way to the front of the line
to the left of me and to the right of me
of my Kenyan brothers and sisters
I even told them my confident bytes away
and see y'all at the finish line then
the gun goes off I started running so
fast it's like I'm running the 100-yard
dash at the Penn Relays
I'm not pacing myself I'm just trying to
keep up with the Kenyans
but then I had a quarter mile and all I
could see was my brothers and sisters
way way way way way way way way way in
the distance then I hit the ten mile
mark and I learned a very important
lesson I learned why people train for
six months see me and the Kenyans we
weren't even in the same brown anymore
they had already finished the race and
then something suddenly it started to
happen to my body something I never felt
before I lost all the sodium in my body
my body my body starts to lock up and
completely break down I couldn't run no
more I could barely walk and then I fell
to my knees so now I'm trying to figure
out I'm gonna get myself out this
situation do I take a cab
do I take your train but as soon as that
thought into my mind all I see is news
cameras all around me and they're going
live we alive for the marathon since the
Kenyans already finished the race the
news went live to see if I was gonna
live or die it got so crazy
I heard that announcer say ooh
Buffy is in trouble now but in all
seriousness I had to make a decision
right there
I had to decide whether I was gonna stay
on my knees or get up on my feet I had
to decide to get up I had to decide to
run my toenails started falling off my
sneakers were soaked in blood Real Talk
I'm not being dramatic but I decided I
was gonna finish that marathon and then
I make it tomorrow 20 thank you Jesus I
made it to Harlem where I was born and
raised see Harlem really doesn't do the
marathon thing but I sort of entire
neighborhood come out there to support
me they had turned my hood into a block
party DJ's playing music people waving
signs yelling go did he go you see my
Harlem family got me through the
marathon just like my Howard family got
me and you to this point today
I finished the marathon I almost died my
feet ain't never been the same since my
feet hurt right now but I finished and I
be Oprah's time and yes uh check did
Claire okay so this is August 9th and
we're about eight and a half miles into
a 15 mile run all the part of the
training for the 26-mile marathon
I've been running now for exactly two
hours straight
exactly
I've had to stop - wee willie winkie
four times it's a bad Willie Winkle day
for me Bob just said well just say hey
got some good news for you
after today you only have ten more long
ones like this week till marathon don't
tell me no bad news okay hi everyone I'm
here with my trainer Andrea and Andrea
will give us some tips on how you can
prevent injuries yeah so because you're
running so much more we want to make
sure that we're keeping those body parts
really strong so some of the common
things that runners deal with have to do
with shin splints and you've had those I
pet them and they were really really bad
plus the knee pain that can show up when
you start to do a lot of distance as
well as arch drop so to prevent those
really painful shin splints we're gonna
make sure that we keep the calves really
strong and the shins flexible so we're
gonna start by doing calf raises
standing nice and tall with your toes
feet apart and then come up on your toes
and strengthen very good so if these are
really strong they're gonna help absorb
some of the movement while you're
running it also will condition your
ankles and give you that stability that
you need to prevent that rolling over I
recommend trying to do at least 20 to 30
and it's great to do them just before
you run to get that warm-up and
conditioning and then to even challenge
yourself stay up at the top it hold
contract users not a problem for me at
all you could run in stilettos I bet I
can
so the next one is to make sure that the
shins are flexible so for that we're
gonna need a mat we're gonna pop down on
our bump we want to strengthen and
stretch out the shins it's really
important to kind of condition those
muscles when you do your shock
absorption so the setup is to extend
this leg nice and long and then from
there pull your toe in and you'll feel
this is the shin muscle that gets really
strong so point and flex your toe a
couple times and then as you pull your
toe up can you feel it activate this
muscle group so we want that to be nice
and strong it's a good idea to do it
before you go on your run to make sure
that it's open and active and then to
stretch it out you're gonna keep your
toe pointed good and just push as hard
as you can and you'll feel it get all
nice and long in here or you can put
that foot on top good advice and push
down push it down even harder yeah so
the third thing that we want to avoid is
the arch drop it's kind of like the arch
underneath starts to get too much
pressure so it's really important to
prevent that because you'll feel it even
when you're not running so the one most
important thing is to get the right shoe
so if your running surface has
absorption it's gonna support the arch
in your foot as well as displace some of
the pressure when you run now when you
already have it and you're having to
deal with it the best way to do it take
off your shoe get a ball and go ahead
and massage it out good so you're gonna
find those hot spots and those pain and
you're gonna put the pressure on now if
it's really tender you're gonna want to
use a nice softer ball but then graduate
eventually and use like a golf ball to
get more pressure on it you would stand
because when you stand you can put more
of your weight on it you get much more
pressure it hurts more yeah it does kind
of good yeah
and then of course you know rest when
you're in a lot of pain from running
sometimes it's just better to take a day
or two off get in your stretching and
your flexibility and then you know hit
the trails a couple days later so make
sure that when you're running you're
gonna keep your eye out for certain
injuries that pop up we went over shin
splints we went over knee pain and we
went over arch drop if you take care of
all those things you'll never have to
get off the running trail and if you're
running with me this summer and make
sure you keep these tips in mind thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Spikers 2108 asked me to
so there's a topic that you'd like me to
cover in the next edition of believe
life leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of the lessons that we're
talking about in this video had the
biggest impact on you leave it in the
comments and I'll Jordan the discussion
thank you so much for watching have a
great day continue to believe and I'll
see you soon